we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P
here is a caller who uses very
disgusting language some of which we've
had to clean up for our broadcast
version of the show
uh but he also is making a point that is
just wrong that I disagree with
just lost my microphone oh my goodness
did you guys see that that was crazy I
literally just lost my microphone let's
see if I can get it plugged back in
okay I don't think that's ever happened
on the show before uh okay that will
probably be memed we're the microphone
is back uh let's listen to the voicemail
hey David I just want to know why you uh
prefer to gargle Joe Biden's nuts
that's a technical term the gargling of
nuts on a regular basis
like I prefer the I prefer The Young
Turks
because they're at least willing to
admit that he is a failure of a
president right give a joke
he does nothing yeah I've not seen that
episode of tyt you you sit back with
their headlines
the major side look good in your own
eyes
you know you know something you'll suck
his nuts
the entire segment that's what you do
so are you funded by the Democratic
party in any capacity or
are you just that much of a show
for the Democratic party I don't
understand
I thought you were smart initially but
oh
now I'll start with doubt my initial
assessment if you're
come on man come on man all right so
let's go through it Point by Point Joe
Biden is uh basically 20 months into his
presidency for the first 17 of those 20
months when Joe Biden had an
accomplishment I would tell you that he
had an accomplishment and my growing
sense was this presidency was not going
well uh the approval rating or lack
thereof reflected that
um there was uh there were long periods
without any major legislative
accomplishments there were
um a number of different
um events that took place for Biden that
were not useful to him and I called out
all of it and yes in the last three of
his 20-month presidency there is New
Life in Joe Biden's presidency a number
of important legislative accomplishments
um a number of good economic factors
that only relate a little bit to Joe
Biden remember as as I always have when
we see something happen in the economy
that doesn't really have anything to do
with the president I gladly tell you
that and I'm mentioned it still helps
the president when good things happen in
the economy so I think that like many
callers one of two things may be going
on one they see one of my Clips in a
vacuum where I pray something Joe Biden
did and their takeaway is that I am
gargling
Joe Biden's let's use a more polite term
Apple bags okay that I'm gargling the
Apple bags uh sucking up to Joe Biden I
guess the phrase would be because they
don't see my other clips and they
haven't been paying attention to the
show long and that's one possibility
other possibility is these people just
don't care and they just want to make
these allegations and
um the third possibility is that they
meant to call a different show that
often will happen I will sometimes get
people who call in they go David that
thing you said about
uh you know someone I've never even
talked about that was absolutely
horrible I'm unsubscribing I don't think
you were even subscribed to me because I
don't even know what you're talking
about so any of these possibilities are
um uh on the table
but I have been very critical of the
Biden Administration the last three
months have been significantly better
for him
and many indicators looking better and
better economically in the United States
that's the reality we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today it turns out
that the incoming King Charles III after
the death of Queen Elizabeth II King
Charles will not have to pay inheritance
tax on the Queen's private estate which
is worth more than 750 million dollars
that's a great deal if you can get it so
we'll talk about what is normally the
inheritance tax in the UK and how it is
that King Charles avoids that we are
going to talk about Nigeria becoming the
first country to ban foreign models and
television ads television ads airing in
Nigeria will have to have models actors
maybe you we would call them who are
Nigerian and we'll talk about why
they're doing it how you enforce such a
rule and more and lastly we are seeing
more and more companies drop vaccine
mandates for covet the most interesting
thing to me about this is that for years
we were hearing from the anti-vaccine
right the vaccine mandates at work are
just the first step in
whatever some dystopian authoritarian
slippery slope of tyranny and we the
reasonable people knew all along that's
not going to happen that's not at all
what this is this is just vaccine
mandates for when it makes sense and
then it's all going to kind of fade away
and that's exactly what happening and
those people are completely silent as at
this point in time all of those stories
and more we will talk about on today's
bonus show when I'm joined by producer
Pat Ford you can sign up at
joinpakman.com couple other things to
tell you about we will be doing a huge
membership special on 919 that's next
Monday Monday September 19th it will be
9 19 themed if you would like to take
advantage of this great membership
special all you need to do is get on my
mailing list at davidpackman.com
and then on the morning of 9 19 you will
get an email telling you exactly how to
sign up for a discounted membership all
right don't miss it it's a doozy my
accountant is saying David don't do it
my business manager is saying David no
our lawyer is saying is this discount
even legal it's so huge and I am saying
we're doing it
we are doing it for the people
and so I look forward to seeing you on
the bonus show either today or after you
get that discounted membership